- Hey everyone, I hope you're having
an amazing day, it's Mark Weins.
We just arrived to Curitiba,
which is in the south of Brazil
in the state of Parana, and
in this video we are gonna
explore Curitiba, we are going
to especially eat some of the
southern Brazilian dishes and
I'm gonna share all of the
southern Brazilian food
with you in this video.
(upbeat music)
Guilherme, how are you man?
- [Guilherme] I'm doing fine man,
I'm very excited for Curitiba.
- [Mark] What's the name of the dish
we're starting with first?
- Carne de Onca.
- [Mark] Carne de Onca.
- [Guilherme] Yes.
- [Mark] Which translates exactly
to the meat of the jaguar.
- Exactly.
(people talking)
- [Mark] Loving the
atmosphere of this restaurant.
It's classic, the wooden
tables, the bar, the antiques,
the Brazilian flag hanging
from the rafter from the roof.
Yeah this is a cool spot.
This just has a classic, just
like heritage feel to it.
The owner was just explaining
to us that this used to be a
corner like convenience shop,
so they would sell,
you could come in here,
you could get your small groceries,
and then eventually it
became a restaurant.
But the house, the property
itself dates back to 1953.
(plates clinking on table)
(mumbling)
Oh that's the meat.
- [Guilherme] That's the meat.
- [Mark] Oh it's so smooth I didn't even.
The meat is such a fine mince
that it almost looked like a
ball of like red pink dough,
but that's actually the minced beef.
Oh, the smoothness of it, it's so fine.
(talking in background)
What is this?
(mumbling)
(percussion music)
(utensils scraping against plate)
Okay, so then first he
took that ball of meat,
he flattened it out,
he mixed in oh he
sprinkled on some cognac,
then some olive oil, salt,
some pepper, some chili powder,
there were some other spices,
some green onions went on there,
and the onions and garlic.
He just mixed it perfectly
and evenly with the two spoons
and served it with bread and some
mustards to go along with it.
- Carne de Onca.
- [Mark] This is the jaguar meat.
Of course it's not really
jaguar it's minced beef.
Do you know the history
of how it got that name?
- [Guilherme] Raw meat, right?
- [Mark] Yeah
- [Guilherme] So when, you know
the bad smell that comes out
of the jaguar mouth after
it eats like raw meat?
- Uh-huh, meat breath.
- So there's nothing
relating to the jaguar but
because after we eat it
gets kind of like a bad
(laughing)
- So we'll have jaguar
breath after we eat this
- Breath, yes.
- So we go bread.
- [Guilherme] Yes.
- [Mark] Butter, I'll use the knife.
Butter goes down first.
You want a good forkful onto the bread.
(kid talking)
You can see all the spices,
you can see the oil,
the cognac, oh and the mustard.
Oh thank you.
- [Guilherme] You're welcome
- [Mark] And that's black mustard?
- [Guilherme] Yes.
- Cheer's man.
- Oh wow, what you immediately notice is
how fine the meat is.
- [Guilherme] Yes.
- [Mark] That's not like
a grind, that's like a,
it is a grind but it's
so fine it's like smooth.
It's absolutely awesome, you taste the
it's not like very very spiced,
but it really focuses on the meat.
You taste that like
hint of cognac I think.
- Yes
- You taste the green onions.
- The sweet paprika.
- Yes, the sweet paprika.
The onions like make it juicy I think.
- [Guilherme] Exactly.
(upbeat music)
- [Mark] And then I will
add some of the hot sauce.
And another thing I love is just how
you one bite that entire thing.
(upbeat music)
it's so like neutral tasting actually.
The beef just has like
zero like overly meaty,
irony taste to it at all.
(customers talking)
Oh man as we're leaving the
restaurant has filled up,
it's packed now.
That was incredibly delicious,
and we only had one dish because
we're gonna eat a lot more
food today in this southern
Brazilian food tour, but
(breathes)
Success.
(walking)
From here, we're going to
the next restaurant which is
walking distance and they are known
for their beef ribs
and this entire region,
this state of Brazil is
known for their meat.
Beef ribs coming up which
is one of the greatest meat
Okay, I can't wait.
- They serve Costelao Do Gaucho.
Costelao is like a big rack,
a huge rack of beef ribs.
I'm already just loving the
atmosphere of this place.
It's laid back, there's kind of like
almost picnic table style dining.
It's busy, it's a family restaurant,
we're going back to the kitchen and
the owner has said we can go back and
see them making the ribs.
30 years.
- [Guilherme] 30 years, yes.
- [Mark] Oh I see him with the barbecue,
and here comes another slab.
(slapping)
(mumbling)
(talking)
(saw squeaks)
And you can even hear the
crispiness of the skin.
The skin so like crackling, crunchy skin.
The owner has been making it for 30 years.
He has this really unique slicing system.
It literally is like a
woodworking table saw,
and he just takes that entire rack and
slices it into pieces, removes the bone.
You can hear again the crispy
skin just like crackling under
that saw and then just like slices
it up expertly with that table saw.
This is the most Brazilian
meat of your dreams.
- [Guilherme] We gonna order the whole
thing which called the happiness combo.
We're in Brazil baby,
let's eat some real ribs.
(laughing)
(waiter speaking Portuguese)
- [Mark] He just brought
over some of the side dishes.
The polenta, there's some
yucca which is a tapioca.
There's some salad, potato salad,
looks like some pickled onions,
some lettuce and some tomatoes and bread.
That's all going to
accompany the main meat.
- [Guilherme] This is the orange,
so keep this to drink with the orange.
- [Mark] This is a local Brazilian soda.
Guarana is a fruit from the Amazon.
This is the soda version of it.
It's almost like a cream soda,
but like with a sour fruitiness.
It's good, it's sweet, it is a soda.
I'm like, I mean I would
definitely prefer the real fruit
but that's interesting and refreshing.
(excited cheering)
(upbeat music)
I like how they serve
it on a chopping board.
You can just like chop it right on there.
The ribs are glistening
with fat and juices and
you can see how crispy that skin is.
Unbelievable, all the side dishes.
- [Guilherme] Yeah, like this.
(speaking in Portuguese)
- [Mark] Just go for the whole thing.
Oh man, the onions, the
onions look amazing.
Pickled red onions.
Look at that skin, if you press it,
if you press it like that you can see
the juices actually like squirting.
Oh, you've got to see that.
(upbeat music)
Okay I have to begin with that bite
right there with the skin.
With the fat, oh wow.
That is the first bite.
Oh wow, that is so flavorful,
it's so smokey it's so tender.
It's so salty, oh it is so good.
All of the juices, the
juices in your mouth, wow.
I can't wait to try this onion either.
It's like a pickled red onion.
Just slightly vinegary and very crisp.
It's really wonderful
because it breaks up like
the fattiness of that meat.
They serve it with some polenta,
which is like a cornmeal fritter.
Oh it's excellent, it's like light,
it's really crispy and
kinda to get that semolina
light and creaminess on the inside.
With some yucca which is
the, these are casaba.
Very starchy, plain, but it's
like a plainness that goes
so well with everything else,
I love it, I love yucca.
Just watch this the meat is so tender
you don't even need a knife,
you can just literally put
your fork in and just twirl.
It's amazing.
(upbeat music)
Dude I like your style.
I watched him over there
as he was vlogging.
He just picked up the entire piece.
(laughs)
This is the way to do it.
- The lizard mouth way.
That's my nickname here in Brazil.
- Just like,
(laughs)
Very juicy, you can just pull it apart.
This is like some chili oil.
Let me add that half an onion.
Okay a meat foundation bite.
- There we go.
- Cheers.
- Break into the bread.
Absolutely awesome, amazing
food, amazing beef ribs.
And I just love this
restaurant, the owner,
the like character of this restaurant.
The food is just insane.
Insanely good.
(speaking Portuguese)
(laughs)
This man, he is a legend.
Obrigado
The owner did not charge us for that meal,
he does that with passion, with love.
What a restaurant, what
a spot, what beef ribs.
That was incredible.
(upbeat music)
Curitiba is located on the
high elevation plateau,
not too high elevation
but high enough so the
weather is cool, the air is so fresh.
It's like 24, 23 degrees today.
Yeah, it's beautiful weather.
(radio music)
(Cars driving past car window)
We drove over to 4 Beans.
This is a coffee shop.
They're a roast coffee as well.
They're one of the top roasters in Brazil,
and we arrived here and they
just said that they're gonna
light up the roaster, they're
gonna fire up the roaster.
They're gonna roast some
coffee fresh for us and
then we're gonna have some coffee.
(upbeat music)
Completely unplanned coffee experience.
- [Guilherme] Yes.
- [Mark] The owners are so nice.
We have a chem ex going with
coffee brewing right here
and then we have some preparing the
green beans which she's gonna roast,
which she's preheating
the roaster over there.
(upbeat music)
- We should drink at the same time.
Very acid.
- [Mark] Acid, but now
sour, and like sweet honey.
That's like drinking fruit
juice, it's incredible.
- Stop so you can see the
beans too, and then like
- That would be awesome.
(mumbling)
(machine grinding)
- Uh, fifteen minutes.
- [Mark] You gotta keep tabs on everything
to roast perfect coffee.
Yeah we're just nerding
out on coffee right now.
- This is a critical moment
- [Mark] A critical moment
okay, no distractions.
(machine pouring)
So we just opened up
this fresh tub of coffee.
It just smells so fruity,
it's like a patch of flowers.
Whoa, that is amazing.
Slightly bitter, chocolatey, crunchy.
(upbeat music)
Okay, next up on this Curitiba food tour.
We've just arrived to a
local little hole in the wall
restaurant that's famous for
serving a sandwich called a
lombado.
They have a five kilo lombado
but after we had that lunch,
those beef ribs, I don't know if we're up
for a challenge for a five kilo sandwich.
So we might just go for the regular size.
But this is the spot, it looks very cool.
(laughs)
What?
- Five kilos. Let's have the five kilos.
Let's have the five kilos please.
The other one is only 1.5 kilos.
- [Mark] Oh, can we see them make it?
Okay, on second thought,
Guilherme has made the executive
decision that we need
to have the five kilo.
- [Guilherme] Yeah,
that's only five kilo man.
- Yeah, let's go with the five kilo.
- Yeah.
- Let's go to the five kilo.
- We're gonna do the five kilo.
- [Guilherme] Five kilo man.
- We're going in, we're going in.
- If we're not at *, man lovely guy.
(kitchen employees talking)
(grill sizzling)
- [Mark] I understand what he's saying.
(chef talking in Portuguese)
- He piled everything into the
bun, starting with the hotdog
then the burgers, then
the chicken mixture,
then that cheese mixture.
There's a white cheese,
there's a cheddar cheese.
It almost looks like a squeezable hotdog
that just like goes on top of it.
Then, he puts on some tomatoes
to balance out that protein,
and then he adds on some
fried eggs, then some lettuce.
I forgot a key ingredient,
half a bucket of mayonnaise
goes onto your bun.
Oh it closes.
Oh my gosh it looks beautiful.
And then he puts it like
literally into a pizza box.
This is not just like a food challenge,
this is just like a family
Saturday night dinner.
The whole family can enjoy and
he just slices it into like pie slices.
(laughs)
Wow.
(server speaks Portuguese)
Look at the cross section.
There's so much chicken and meat in there.
And cheese, there has to
be like a kilo of cheese.
- [Guilherme] Yeah and
two kilos of chicken.
- [Mark] There's a hotdog
protruding out of this piece.
You have to actually like put
your palm underneath this.
You have to support it.
(laughs)
Oh it's so hot.
Oh I lost some at the front.
Oh wow, that's.
- Grab the top.
- Grab the top, it's flaming
hot, I'm gonna use that piece
of lettuce to scrape out
and stuff it back in.
The cheese, the chicken, the hotdog,
I have a protruding hotdog,
the burgers, the egg.
Oh wow, okay, cheers.
- Cheers.
(upbeat music)
It's actually awesomely good.
Just like so much cheese.
You really taste the hotdog,
you really taste the burger.
(laughs)
(Guilherme talking)
It's stuck to my fingers.
(talking)
(laughing)
No, like plastic bags of cheese,
they're just completely
melted into everything.
The shredded chicken has
like a crusty, crunchy edge.
You get the saltiness of the hotdog.
I know there's burger in there,
but I haven't even tasted the burger yet.
The edge is just like oozing around,
and then all of a sudden you
hit the refreshing taste of the
lettuce and the tomato to
balance everything of course.
You can imagine yourself
just lounging on the couch
just finishing an entire 5 kg lombado.
It's actually really good though.
- [Guilherme] It's very good.
- Let's explore the sauces,
I think I'm going with the mustard.
- Oh, that's like transparent yellow.
I don't know if that's mustard or not.
I think it's like a sweet mustard.
Oh, the end of a hotdog.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, awesome.
That is gonna be key.
That is gonna be a key bite right there.
And you can see in this bite
there's gonna be all that
chili, plus burger, plus hotdog, plus egg.
So far in Brazil I've just been
loving the different chili sauces.
The actual food is not that spicy but
they always have chili sauce
which is just unbelievable.
And this is an amazing
one, the mix of chilis.
This chili sauce, oh no I lost it.
Okay let me put it back on there.
This chili sauce really makes it though.
Okay, I'm moving in for my
second piece here of the lombado.
This thing is mega-normous.
It's beyond huge.
- Good job.
- This is like it's
actually very very tasty,
the mix of meats,
the saltiness all combined
with the chili sauce,
this is like this will make you just
stop for the rest of the evening.
What a place, this is
like a community hangout.
Not only is it a restaurant,
Yeah this is a community hangout.
And man, I love the people,
I love how he started as a
street food cart outside of a speed bump
and now this is what
he has turned it into.
A restaurant where literally like
the five kilo family platter lombado.
It's just like flying out of the kitchen.
He's making one after
another, after another,
after another, after
another, and just like
boxing them and they're
like going out the door.
Oh yeah, there's one right there.
(rain dripping)
(cars driving through puddles)
One more stop today to
finish this food tour.
It's called Uncle Dog.
It's like a bit of a giant hotdog.
(talking)
Being able to stand here
on the corner and making it
it is really cool.
They like pack in the
ingredients, and there's like
tomatoes, and corn and the
little crispy shoestring fries.
I mean, literally folds it
in and packs it in with his
spatula before flattening it down.
It's a lot of things
going on in that hotdog,
that's for sure.
(talking)
He's using a trowel to make that,
to fit everything in that bun.
And we're gonna order
one of the Philadelphia.
I think it's one of their top sellers.
(talking)
Oh yeah look at that cross section.
The squeezable cheese are all in there.
The mayonnaise, the hotdog
on both sides of the bread.
The little shoestring fries
and the tomato mixture.
That ones pretty good.
Like a sweet corn, the
creamy like liquid cheese.
The crunch of the fries
and just the heat of it.
This is a definitely a 2 A.M. food.
(talking)
- So what do you think about the taste?
Pretty good?
- Definitely good.
- Nice.
- Different and definitely good.
- My grandpa starts this, all of this.
- So it's part of your family.
- Yeah.
- Wow very cool.
- Last bite.
- [Mark] Nice.
(cheering)
- [Mark] The entire crew here
at Tio Dog is so awesome,
they're so friendly, they're
having a good time out here
making the tio dogs,
making the Philadelphia.
Yeah, what I love most
about this is the atmosphere
and just hanging out
with this crew of guys.
They are absolutely awesome and just
like having so much fun.
It has been a very interesting,
very unique food day.
A delicious, meaty food day.
I want to say a huge thank
you for watching this video
and if you haven't seen all
the videos in this entire
Brazil series, I'm gonna be
publishing a bunch of Brazil
videos, so I'll have the link
all in the description box
that you can check out this
Brazil and food travel series.
And I want to say again a big thank you
for watching this video
and also Guilherme,
I want to say a huge thank you to
Guilherme and Raphaela
for arranging everything.
They're so much fun to hang out with and
I'll have their links in
the description box below.
He also made a video today and yeah,
thanks again for watching.
Good night from Curitiba
in Parana, Brazil.
See you on the next video.